hi everybody sorry for the little
difficulty there thanks for joining us
and this will be a presentation on
zebrafish husbandry and what I hope to
do is provide an overview of successful
practices we're going to jump right in
with probably what I would say is the
most important single aspect and one of
the things that I come back to time and
time again when people do approach me
with problems in their facility and
that's water quality and really bottom
line here is to just keep it stable you
may hear that from other people and i'm
just going to echo the exact same
sentiment if you keep it stable you're
officially happy these zebrafish exhibit
a wide range of tolerance and most of
these water quality parameters that we
can control in the lab but stability is
the goal when accidents do happen and
they do happen reverse them gradually
just bear in mind that you've already
put them into a state of stress by
pushing some or multiple parameters out
of their normal range and really the
goal is to not give them any more stress
than really needed so reverse it
gradually so what happens let me give
you an example a dosing pump goofs up
and suddenly you're conductivity goes
from eight hundred micro siemens to two
thousand micro siemens it's absolutely
not
big of a deal you should be concerned
about preventing it from happy in it
from happening again in the future but
the answer isn't to dump all the water
and replenish with fresh or ro and to
get the conductivity back down as quick
as possible just let it come back down
nice and slow using the typically the
automated water exchange that's in these
systems so temperature and controlling
of water quality temperature is one of
the things that actually impacts
virtually every water chemistry
characteristic and it does have a direct
metabolic impact on the animals as well
so the range of tolerance is just
massive all the way down the you know
seven degrees Celsius and up to 42 and
indeed there are even heat shock
protocols for adult fish that take them
up to 42 degrees for a number of time
something on the order of an hour or two
so it is actually a functional range the
target for us it is typically 28 and a
half degrees the reasons for that are
mostly for synchronicity and development
from one lab to another and it just
happens to be pretty widespread in terms
of its use you can obviously raise them
at higher and lower temperatures and
that includes embryos and adult fish pH
power hydrogen the tolerance is pretty
wide I would actually say that it
probably use fish can probably handle
something even lower than six and I know
that they can handle slightly above nine
and a half I've seen them at 10 makes me
pretty nervous but they can tolerate it
you just don't want to do it for a long
time
and again reversing these changes
somewhat gradually is the goal if if an
accident happens the details about pho
are probably fairly elementary to most
people that are doing any water quality
work with any aquaculture work with fish
but they will respirate they will
fluctuate in these research systems
based on nitrification and respiration
remember respiration is producing co2
and what it dissolves in the water
you've got carbonic acid typically in
zebrafish systems we only dose with
something like sodium bicarbonate or a
buffer so our only real control in most
of these systems is to bring pH up very
rarely are people using acids to bring
pH down water hardness comes in two
varieties again a huge range of
tolerance here the target is above 100
ppm it's very very difficult to do
typically it means that we have to have
some sort of a reactor to dissolve
something like crushed coral which is
available in San form and in large
particle form as well general hardness
is one of the measurements that that we
use it's really common uses the script
tests to measure water chemistry and I
think most of them are fantastic and
they were quickly in pretty consistently
alkalinity is the other measure of
hardness also known as KH or carbonate
hardness and specifically with respect
to general harness the the effect that
you need to be thinking about
metabolically is that in a situation of
increased general hardness the fish are
a challenge to keep the ions basically
in their body because they're
the water is trying to steal it from
them so when you increase that general
hardness it decreases the stress of the
fish for Ozma regularity it also
decreases the toxicity of dissolved
metals like copper and zinc and those
are pretty important because they're not
those metals are actually fairly common
in municipal water supplies and
depending on the type of research system
that you have there may be components of
your pump and valves and pressure
transmitters and things like this that
contain some of these metals and of
course copper can be pretty toxic to
fish so anything we can do to minimize
the toxicity of metals that may exist in
these systems is a good thing soft water
low anions is kind of repeating myself
but it's it's difficult for these fish
to maintain that homeostasis through
Ozma regulation and soft water
conditions so lastly with respect to
general hardness the higher hardness
levels can actually increase the
facility facilitating of that Ozma
regulation and not only oside production
but also bone formation and maintenance
carbonate hardness this is one where we
are often adding to the carbonate
hardness in our systems by dosing for pH
because we're using sodium bicarbonate
some of the other buffers that are found
in for example synthetic sea salts like
instant ocean that people commonly use
it's also good to keep that alkalinity
high as well for the very same reason
its general hardness for the toxicity of
things like copper and zinc and even
aluminum salinity and conductivity the
salinity tolerance is really massive to
ppt I think is a really conservative
tolerance level I've seen these fish
totally swimming and happy in four parts
per thousand that's a pretty big
increase from two parts per thousand and
in fact it's really common for people to
use in the fish trading in fish health
to use salt in salinity to help deal
with illness or pathogens if the fish
can tolerate a rapid increase and to a
higher salt level a lot of the pathogens
that they can be afflicted with and that
includes parasites don't tolerate it
connectivity tolerance conductivity and
salinity are essentially directly
related look at the target that we have
here three to twelve hundred micro
siemens i can tell you that for example
in our nursery here at Wash U we run
that system at 2000 micro siemens all
the time and it's not uncommon to see it
jump up to close to 3000 for example
when we start flow on a lot of tanks
that have previously been static and
been sitting with rotifers in them once
that water gets flushed into the system
it has an impact on a full system be the
ability to modify salinity and
conductivity are done typically
hand-in-hand and that's also through
dosing with salt and my preference here
is to use a blend of two things and one
is a food grade salt just ninety-nine
point nine nine percent pure sodium
chloride and we're using a little bit of
Instant Ocean as well mostly because of
the buffering capacity in it it should
be pointed out that instant ocean has
zero has absolutely zero actual sea
water in it it's all lab made from lab
quality ingredients some of them are
technical grade and some of them are
food grade some of them may even be
pharmaceutical grade but these folks are
not going out and evaporating sea salt
selling you what's left the sodium ions
are necessary for these fish so we
definitely don't want to keep them at
too low of salt concentration they'll be
working very hard to try and get it from
assault or even from their food the
processes of that regulatory function
have a high metabolic costs the fish
usually comes in the form of respiration
and it will also come in the form of
causing them to either eat a lot more or
a lot less depending on which end of the
spectrum the problems at do and I want
to make sure that that that we all
notice that this is totally different
from total dissolved gas pressure or
total gas pressure or total dissolved
gas tdpt DGP tgp these are all terms for
the same thing in the case of dissolved
oxygen we would like to keep that eighty
percent or greater saturation at this
temperature it's pretty hard to get a
hundred percent saturation for very long
cold water holds oxygen better warm
water has a much more difficult time
holding on to it we can do some
additional aeration with these systems
but typically if the water is flowing in
a research zebrafish system you have
enough oxygen but you can use things
like venturi gas injectors that are
simply injecting breathing air room air
into it you have to be very very careful
when you do this sort of thing and these
monitors for total gas pressure are
becoming really ubiquitous in zebrafish
systems typically this is perpetuated by
the horror stories of gas bubble disease
hyperoxia is the technical technical
term for this it can be used in the
right hands too
managed really high density aquaculture
situations but that's not really what
we're doing in these labs so you really
want to try and stay away from it so a
quick review on on water quality of
those culture condition guidelines this
isn't the tolerances but these are the
ranges that the majority of people are
maintaining these at temperature of 18
to 24 sorry that's 18 to 28 degrees
Celsius my mistake oppo entity if you
can keep it on the high end of this of
this range you'll be doing great the
same goes for hardness 80 is pretty
typical around here and I'm still
running some crushed coral it's still
very difficult to keep it I love seeing
it around 100 but that typically happens
in nursery where we've got higher
connectivity to begin with pH of 6 to 8
i'm pretty happy about 7.4 7.5 it seems
to be a pretty good number in terms of
stability with our systems salinity I
prefer to look at that in terms of
conductivity we run our adult systems at
850 micro siemens which is pretty close
to the middle of the road for this range
ammonia ania nice you want to keep it
really really low please be aware this
is different from total ammonia nitrogen
the percentage of an ionized ammonia in
your total ammonia nitrogen will very
specifically in relation to ph night
right I prefer to see at zero as well
but less than one milligram per liter of
1 ppm nitrate it's nice to keep it less
than 50 but you're going to see swings
and that value based on the time of day
that you
get your water quality testing and if
you do your water quality testing for
some of these parameters within 30
minutes of feeding they're not going to
be the same as they are 30 minutes
before feeding ori you want to have
absolutely none of it in your system do
again eighty percent or better and co2
if you measure it less than five
milligrams per liter just a review on
that total gas pressure and and gas
bubble disease or hyperoxia when the
when a son total pressure of all of the
gases in that water exceeds the
atmospheric pressure you start to have
the super saturation and the effect is
it is well documented if you know people
in this field you probably have heard a
story or may know someone who has had
this problem and the realities of it are
that it happens very quickly you've got
very little time 10 minutes or less
typically to correct the situation
typically that means shutting down the
water until you can figure out what your
problem is if you have a second pump to
switch over to that's usually a very
good way to get started to see if you
can get the pressure back down here are
some examples a number of these slides
are courtesy of Jason cockington in
Australia he's in Queensland and he
shared with me a number of these slides
some of our colleagues of sent these
slides around to help us see you know
what this looks like you can actually
see in the fins and the dorsal fin of
this fish its closest the bubbles in the
fin these fish are doing their very very
best to get rid of that excess gas and
if they can't do it pretty quickly
bill parrish pretty quick so next topic
is nutrition this one's a pretty hot
topic these days of zebrafish and I'm
going to cover a number of items here
and we'll probably do full circle on
nutrition a couple of times first in
this section and then again when we get
into some specifics about Laura culture
and breeding so the nutrient
requirements for proteins and amino
acids specifically these are required to
provide these indispensable amino acids
and the non indispensable ones and
nitrogen these are typically found in
our in our foods and the demand for
these varies not only with species but
even with life stages and that is
definitely true for zebrafish the total
requirement really is the minimum
protein that's needed to satisfy the
demand and as I mentioned just before
this it does change with life stages we
typically start these fish with much
much higher protein when they're young
and start to reduce it with some of the
adult diets the diets with the excess
proteins will increase ammonia
production that's a result of the
metabolism of fish you'll also see this
manifest as sort of a foam I've had
people sort of almost panicked as they
see a foam within 10 or 15 minutes of
heavy feeding and it almost looks like
soap in the water this is one of the
reasons that protein fractionators or
foam fractionators are used in
aquaculture and if you feed to excess or
have a big facility that a lot of food
goes into all the same time you may see
this in there in your sump sander the
tanks and in other areas and although
maybe just a few
years ago if I hadn't asked I would have
said the protein skimmers were really
not needed in in these particular
systems I certainly changed my mind
about that over the last couple of years
as I've seen a higher-quality diets and
higher protein diets become available
and we've started using them and we can
see the protein the diets that we're
using for zebrafish have a 29 250 51%
crude protein content and it seems to
support the optimal growth for other
sipra needs things like Fathead minnows
and gold shiners and these are fish
species where a lot of nutritional work
has been done and it appears to sort of
overlap or mesh with what we see in
terms of performance from zebrafish
lipids fats these are an important
source of energy the essential or
non-essential fatty acids the poly onset
polyunsaturated fatty acids these are
things that are starting we're starting
now to get a very decent handle really
on what works best with zebrafish
although I have to say that not nearly
enough work has been done to date
published work has been done to really
say what the ideals are for the Latin
various life statism zebrafish the
zebrafish do possess that enzymatic
machinery to elongate some of the pufas
into the pufas the highly unsaturated
fatty acids but if they can be provided
in the diet then that reduces the
metabolic cost to the fish to get this
particular lipid EPA and DHA and r a
canonic acid these are all things that
we're finding as supplements or
additives in a lot of the foods that are
used the zebrafish today one of these
aspects of fish nutrition it's sort of
peculiar is that in zebrafish they
display this typical warm water pattern
where we have a higher in 62 in 3 ratio
and most commercially diets that are
available really are formulated in
exactly the opposite way and it really
seems to be sort of driven by the
economy of aquaculture in general there
are not a lot of warm water fish that
end up on dinner plates so as a result
we don't have a lot of these
commercially available bulk manufactured
diets that are really good for this
particular ratio higher end 62 n3 the
specifics for zebrafish again are
unknown I can be a broken record and say
that for virtually every slide in this
nutrition section carbohydrates there is
no no dietary requirement for
carbohydrates and fish it is an
important source of energy it's used for
binding feeds it's it's an important
filler and feed manufacturing it's it's
much less expensive than some of the
other binders like fish meal and so it
is commonly used the ability for
zebrafish to digest these simple and
complex carbohydrates is not well
understood because these fish are
essentially omnivorous they do ingest
digest and incorporate aspects of
phytoplankton we have to imagine that
they have some ability to assimilate
nutritionally some of the carbohydrates
but
the degree to which they can really do
this is not well understood and from my
perspective I would say that they get it
much more efficiently if it's already
gun loaded into an organism it is
adapted to eating it like some of these
invertebrates so Robinson at all
concluded that zebrafish can display
good growth rates at inclusion rates of
up to twenty five percent and really we
don't need any more than five percent
and excess levels may actually decrease
growth and reproduction then furthermore
the when you're increasing the amount of
carbohydrates and these diets or
decreasing the amount of something else
so remember it's better to get some of
these fish meals and some of these other
proteins and ingredients into the fish
food vitamins we know that some of these
are essential in what amounts we don't
really know all that much we do know
that a DEA que si diamond for late
number of these are essential for fish
they do have to be provided in the diet
there is some indication that some of
their gut microbial microbial gut
contents may be able to manufacture some
of these for them the live feeds are
very often rich in these vitamins and
that requirement can be satisfied by
giving them some of these live feeds
there are common in zebrafish again the
specifics for zebra fish are completely
unknown vitamin C sorbic acid and
they've all been shown to be important
the long-term production of quality
gametes and growth reproduction and fish
however just because it's in the diet
that you're feeding your fish doesn't
mean that they're getting it will cover
a little bit of that in a moment but
vitamin C and some of these
vitamins are a little bit delicate and
they require that you handle them
properly mineral requirements these are
inorganic elements that are required to
the fishing trace amounts they're
important for Bill information
osmoregulation nervous system function
etc they can be obtained to the diet but
they can also be obtained through the
external environment where the water
essentially across absorption through
their gills or even through the
ingestion of the water that's in there
that is their environment and this
actually goes back to water quality
where we're using the correct buffers
and we may be dissolving something like
crushed coral to provide some of these
minerals these live feeds also often
contain these either in their shell or
their gut contents the dietary
requirement will depend on your water
chemistry so when we go look back that
up water chemistry slide those water
chemistry slides keeping those hardness
values up will reduce the amount that
you need to provide in the feed so feed
types that are available for fish wyd
feeds and formulated feats early there's
two types the most common live feeds
Sega zebrafish our arty Mia rotifers and
silly it's like Paramecium the
formulated feeds come in actually a
handful of varieties pellets or pellets
and a mash or crumble the matter crumble
i should say probably often starts out
as a pellet and then it's broken and
sipped to a variety of sizes and then
packaged as such the flakes are
typically a solution that is spray dried
and then scraped we've probably all seen
something like tetraman flake that's at
your local pet store you get your
goldfish it's great for your goldfish
it's not great for aquaculture lower
performance of your fish in terms of
production and growth is important the
larval diets come in some of these forms
as well some of them are also available
in a liquid form so specifically talking
about some of the advantages and
disadvantages of live feeds the
advantages are probably without way the
disadvantages yet the amenability of
mass culture and what I mean by that is
that you can relatively easy easily
culture a number of live organisms in
the lab in buckets or cones or cylinders
that are made specifically for this
purpose inductor cones vessels etc and
they have great nutritional profiles
often on their own they also have the
ability to gut moed which is really one
of the most important parts for some of
these smaller foods and first feeding
items like Road first they're highly
digestible they're attractive because
they have not only a motion that
attracts fish what we often called a
live prey feeding response but they
undoubtedly have a smell as well that's
an attractant some of the disadvantages
is that they can they can be variable in
their nutritional profile this is often
a result of the way in which that they
are handled or harvested or even just
simply the way that their culture
labor-intensive and I have a question
mark here because I think that most
people have this notion that they are
labor-intensive before they really get
into it before they really get used to
doing it and get good at it I would
counter by saying that with respect to
rotifers that it is much less
labor-intensive for me to culture
harvest and use rotifers
but it is certainly than it is for for
RT Mia and we're not even culturing
arcania were just simply hashing them so
labor-intensive I think is up for debate
and it really depends on your expertise
in your experience they can be a source
of pathogens there's absolutely no doubt
about it that's very much true with
respect to RT Mia these are wild
harvested wild pot organisms and if you
really look through a microscope even at
the dry cysts in here RT Mia cans you'll
find feathers and a number of things
that happen to be very similar in size
to the RT me assists and therefore
they're not something they're not
filtered out and so it requires
additional work that aspect definitely
makes our tinea more labor intensive and
I'm specifically referring to bleach
encapsulation this is a picture of the
first instar RT nyan ah Polly I you
don't know what they look like you need
to pull some of them out of your culture
tank before you feed them and get
familiar with what they look like in
your body plan these are necrotic
crustacean and they are relatively easy
to culture they're definitely easy to
hatch they have a good nutritional
profile in general as long as you don't
let them go too far bio encapsulation
when they're used properly and what I
mean by that is that at the stage that
you see this image these organisms don't
have a mouth and they don't have a
complete gut track so if you start
dumping cellco or something in there to
enrich them you would be just as well
advised to dump it down the drain
because these fish are these are tinea
nopalea are incapable or incorporating
into their tissues in order to do that
you have to raise them well beyond this
stage and one of the major advantages to
RT monopoly I disappears when you do
that they become bigger and they're not
readily available to your smallest fish
well paramecium still pretty commonly
used your freshwater ciliate they have a
limited nutritional value they are
fairly easy to culture I will tell you
they're quite stinky and getting culture
containers of paramecium up to the
densities that you can very easily do
with rotifers is very challenging they
are good for a first feeding item by
comparison to lots of other things
particularly prepared diets because they
move and they they presumably also
possess an odor and and so on but I will
show you a couple of videos that
illustrate how they differ from some of
the other live organisms the third wifey
type rotifers these are a small aquatic
invertebrate plankton this is so
plankton they exist both in salt and
freshwater they have limited nutritional
value on their own however they are
still superior to pair museum in that
respect the the real point to think
about here is that these these organisms
will readily incorporate any number of
lg's etc that you want to feed them
people have used yeast and rice bran and
a number of things to maintain these
cultures and one of the great things
about that is that you can have a great
stable culture on a rather inexpensive
diet and then when you do your harvest
to feed out to your fish your laudable
fish in particular you can follow an
enrichment protocol and essentially gut
load these guys with some stuff it's
really fantastic for your larval
zebrafish and one of the things that
that I really like about them is that
they are relatively easy to culture in
mass quantities we regularly grow the
rotifers here at Wash U between 750 and
a thousand per milliliter the strain
that we're using the right now is an
s-type and they're only about thirty
five microns so they're nice and small
and the larval fish just go bananas over
them I should also say the adult fish do
too but we're really really happy with
the results that we get using a river
this next slide is a video clip of the
rotifer and what I hope to illustrate
here is sort of this lumbering movement
that rotifers exhibit
you
that they can't raise at all and they've
actually called them very often they
have very often called them homozygous
lethal but the reality is that the
homozygous lethal label that they get
branded with may actually just simply be
a result of the fact that the fish can't
get to the food that's being offered to
them and we've watched these fish that
some really sick we finish with terrible
edema and other problems phenotypes that
are that are a product of their genotype
we've watched them eat in a petri dish
without really even moving and the
rotifers basically bump into them and
they eat them and this is not something
that happens with certainly not with
prepared diets and I've never seen it
happen with Paramecium show you a video
clip in just a moment a Paramecium and
their movement is fast and it's often a
straight line it's very difficult for
the fish to catch them comparatively
speaking I'm going to answer a question
that's come to me real quickly
environmental enrichment doesn't make a
difference the the fact that you are
providing in a sense environmental
enrichment to the fish by giving them
alive prey item to chase a meat is
undoubtedly making an impact on the fish
qualifying and quantifying the effect of
that enrichment has not been done to my
knowledge I would love to see it done we
know that a number of scientists have
used things like rotifers to elicit
neurological responses in two and three
and four day old marble fish and this is
now starting to become well documented
the effects of that movement of a prey
item across the
or field of the fish we know that they
physically will move their eyeball to
follow the organism and it elicits a
pattern of firing and the neurons of
that zebrafish brain so to directly
answer the question about environmental
enrichment if indeed this is in
reference to live feeds I think it does
make a difference and you're absolutely
right it's not not little covered in the
literature let me knock out a couple
questions here any experience with
breeding medaka no I don't have any
personal experience breeding medaka and
do you use the same parameters my gut
feeling is that they're probably not
very different in terms of the water
quality parameters that are used but
those water quality parameters are
available through some literature search
as well all right I'm going to advance
here so on me on the notion of live
feeds there are still a couple of dry
foods that are available that were live
feeds things like blood worms chronomat
larvae tubifex worms there are a number
of them out there that people use and
some of them to great success but you
should be cautious about things like to
but X worms and blood worms they really
should be avoided they transmit
nematodes and other parasites to viveks
worms are actually a host of a severe
neurological pathogen in Salman it's and
it's just not an area that's probably
worth getting into if you don't have to
their grade in Richmond I think for the
home aquaria their grade in the pet
trade etc but
it's not one of the things that I would
personally recommend for a number of
reasons in the setting of laboratory
aquaculture raising a superfish to talk
about some of these formulated diets so
the advantages and disadvantages there
the disadvantages are largely related to
the choice of food and that you use the
formulated diet and how it's stored is
extremely important and how it's
delivered is also very very important so
the advantages include the fact that
many of them and I want to be specific
here many of the high quality
aquaculture formulated feeds things that
are designed to impart success to fish
farmers whose livelihoods mortgages etc
rely on the standard metric of feed
conversion ratio these are actually
designed to replace live diets I would
not extend that quality to something
like tetraman flake they are cheaper and
easier to use than live diets in
virtually every case they're easy to
quantify meaning how much of the
nutritional any nutritional parameter is
going into the into the fish and how
much food you're putting into the system
you can deliver a known amount with
those specific nutrients they have a
higher dry weight than live diets in
fact sometimes it's exponential
disadvantages come from things like
complete replacement of nutritional
requirements are difficult to achieve if
you don't really know what those
requirements are water stability varies
not only from fee to feed but
particularly with the type of formulated
feed and there
attractiveness and palatability berries
you may have seen fish gobble up a
palette of food and spit it right back
out and do it over and over and over and
over and over again that to me is not a
palatable diet the best of these
formulated feed type charlie is going to
be a pellet and the narrow size
distribution is a huge advantage if they
have decent to good water quality
stability some of them can still look
like they just went into water 20 30 40
minutes later they have a predictable
nutritional profile one of the best
aspects physical aspects of these pellet
diets is that they're free flowing they
don't clump they don't compact certain
types can be used exclusively in
zebrafish it's important to know about
the food that you're buying because
every feed is different these processed
fee types that are a masher or crumble I
mentioned before they start out as a big
pellet they crush them they have a much
wider size distribution the stability of
the water quality is decent compared to
something like flake but you'll often
see in them to grade rather quickly it
is somewhat free-flowing but it does
have a tendency to clump and this is
largely due to those irregular shapes
that sort of mash and bind with one
another and form a bigger piece there
are a lot of them commercially available
and some even claim to be complete for
zebra fish flake type looks like Thai
food huge size distribution they are
really unstable 30 seconds into getting
in the water there they're falling apart
m and the nutritional quality
nutritional content is getting leached
into the water and that's gone these
larvae feeds are usually micro pellets
or or a narrow range of the crusher
crumble there's lots of them available
that a use for zebrafish the micro
encapsulated ones are really very good
because they're their various
water the performance of zebrafish
larvae can be pretty good if you know
what you're doing but it's very labor
intensive and it's very easy to make a
mistake and over feet of tank lower
growth rates and typically lower
survival rates compared to live foods
the handling and storage of live feeds
is important as it is with with those
dry feeds they need to be harvested in
fed out as close to that patching period
as possible in particular with with our
tinea unless you're going to enrich it
and you're talking about waiting at
least another six to eight hours so from
a labor perspective and from a planning
perspective and a zebrafish facility
this is not done very often and it's
maybe not all that great of an idea in
most cases when these other alternatives
are available but nah Polly I will
suffocate and die unless they're really
heavily rated so when you collect your
martini you need to feed them out
immediately and keep them aerated for as
long as possible they can be collected
in fish water and kept it at 4 degrees
for several hours before feeding and
they sort of slow everything down and
they'll most of it will stay alive but
you need to be looking at them under the
microscope to make sure that what your
practices are really providing what you
expect then you're Isis can be stored
for years and in fact 23 years is
probably a really conservative estimate
the de capsulated cysts can be stored in
a hyper saline solution for several
weeks we typically d capsulate something
on the order of three weeks to a month
of our tinea at a time these processed
feeds doesn't matter if it's a flake or
a pellet or crumple oil powder the
nutrients can leach out rapidly when
they're hydrated so they need to be fed
dry meaning not putting them in a bottle
of filling it up with water and
squirting that into the ten
that's it's just not a good practice and
it's actually pretty well understood why
I'm actually going to show you a couple
of graphics here as well storage heat
moisture and light are important factors
these are perishable foods keep them
cold keep them in the dark freezing is
maybe not a great idea unless it's
particularly directed by the
manufacturer because when you pull these
things out of the freezer condensation
forms on them and if you put them right
back in the freezer after you get what
you want you're going to end up with a
pretty degraded product so speaking
specifically about leaching of
water-soluble vitamins when you put some
of these diets particularly the ones
that are not micro encapsulated into the
water within 30 seconds you experienced
a tremendous amount of loss of a number
of important water soluble vitamins
particularly vitamin C it's just almost
gone this is water soluble protein
leaching when you hydrate some of these
diets and you've only got about a minute
really is the take home message here to
get all that food into the fish and when
we think about how we're asked if he'd
association in five to ten minutes you
can see that within five minutes they're
gone this is a video that was shared
with me by Chris Lawrence thanks Chris
if you're any of your colleagues are out
there and this video shows a good way of
delivering some of the dry feeds this is
video for slide 38 the fee
tanks pellet with this new dispenser
simply depress the plunger all away
allowing the feed to flow through the
tube and into tank ensure that all the
food from each plunge flows into the
tank before moving on to the next one
spreads out when it hits the water I'm a
big fan of these videos for training
purposes and in fact that's what that
video was forms was training purpose to
show someone how to do it properly
there's really nice to see and i
remember being pretty excited that first
time I saw that particularly one of you
are able to see how the food distributed
itself across the water so the
generalities the specific nutrients
nutrient requirements are unknown you
can feed them just about anything and
still get results and I know people that
fed them single-celled organisms
bacteria yeast etc and they can still
get results the right diet does make a
difference when it comes to spawning
success and survival and growth and even
gamme quality and Riaan function a huge
variety of aspects of fish culture
suboptimal diets will give you
suboptimal output in all of those areas
along with water chemistry poor
nutrition is the most important cause of
problems in zebrafish facilities that's
particularly the case for reproduction
feeding approaches these fish need to
change not only the quality and the
nutrient profile with the quantity and
the frequency of feeding the feeding
regime and diet really needs to be
adjusted according to a live station I'm
going to go back to that in the next
couple slides here the things that Tim
tend to increase with the age of the
fish are flow rates because you need
more water exchange in the Twitter
better handle able to handle it the
amount of feed tends to increase at a
given feeding as does the particle size
of Olympic
content conversely the feed frequency
tends to decrease as the fish age the
daily feed input becomes more relevant
to the percent of the body weight of the
fish and the protein content tends to
decrease as well as they get older so
this knows it notion of larval stage
feeding for the five to thirty days when
you really start to optimize some of
these feeding techniques the range here
probably comes becomes more like five to
twenty days or five to fifteen days we
want high nutrient high protein content
in these really young fish forty to
sixty percent lots of fat six to fifteen
percent these need to be stable in the
water column live feeds really can be
the best for this initial first feeding
it's great to have these feeds that are
in suspension rather than negatively
buoyant or positive would win because
this is where the fish tend to spend
most of their time on these first
feeders there's really no way to get
something into their mouth and down the
throat of it's bigger than a couple
hundred microns but as soon as they grow
you can start to increase the size of
the food these are pretty simple a
gastric fish and these feeds in need to
be highly digestible specifically with
respect to those fats and proteins
hydrolyzed proteins seem to be on the
rise in these diets that are available
and the really single work very well
acceptability this is probably also
palatability these larvae need something
moving to really be efficient feeders
something moves and how does it a smell
to stimulate them the feet again live
feeds are the best the densities of food
what we aim for here is to have a really
high encounter rate meaning that there's
a ton of
prefers in the tank so that these fish
are essentially bumping into food all
the time that's almost impossible to do
with prepared diets they essentially
need to be fed constantly which is why
we like to essentially perform a
co-culture where we have fish and
rotifers in the same tank up until the
point where they can eat bigger items
the juvenile stage 30 to potentially 90
days these numbers are coming from from
dzifa and from a lot of the common
literature but we're good we're going to
review them again in the next section
where I'm going to challenge the
dilution of some of these time ranges
being linked to a state a live stage of
the fish as they get older again the
protein is still pretty high and so is
the lipids but they can start to come
down sorry they can start to increase in
the food size these fish don't
necessarily need just suspended feeds at
that time they can feed in the top to
the bottom of the water quality or out
the water column they still need to be
highly digestible because the fish are
still a gastric menos throughout their
whole life really the same palatability
acceptability is true for juveniles as
it is for larval fish same is true for
density and frequency the adult stage
here's that ubiquitous number of 90 days
which i will bet i'll definitely be
challenging and asking you to think
about and challenge in the future we
drop the protein when they get to this
age we drop the amount of fat that's
really needed but we do want to talk
more about how they are proof of a
content in these feeds particularly for
gamete production they still need to be
highly stable diets they can feed
anywhere in the water column anything
greater than about 750 or eight or eight
hundred microns is just too big for
adult zebrafish it's really not necess
he still needs to be digestible the
density of food or the amount of food
that you're giving their fish this is
where we start to look at aquaculture
standards where one to five percent of
the body weight daily is what needs to
be given to these fish depending on your
application this number can increase if
you have like routine breeding fish but
you still may keep an eye on it to
maintain healthy fish you're not obese
fish or egg bound fish feeding of these
fish one to a few times a day depending
on what they're being used for here's a
couple of videos for slide number 45 you
can use behavioral cues of these fish to
indicate how much food is enough there's
a video that's going to pop up here on
the left and we're going to compare that
to the video that we see on the right so
that video was our left hand video and
really the the thing that is important
to notice is those fish were all over
the water column and they were
traversing the water column up and down
and right and left the attitude that
they have in the water was often moving
and almost a searching sort of behavior
the second video for slide 4045 will
show some different behaviors so you can
see these nice sort of distended bellies
in these these fish are just sort of
horizontal in the water column and
they're just swimming and moving they're
not exhibiting these behaviors that are
sort of searching I'm going to answer a
couple of a couple of questions real
quick what's the ideal target density
for zebra fish in a research research
system unfortunately I don't think there
is an ideal target density I think a lot
of it has to do with what your goals are
and what your system can handle
in terms of its biological filtration
and the amount of oxygen that's in these
systems I'm only about half way through
the presentation than I'm already
essentially at the end of my allotted
time but I'm going to keep running on
until they get the hook out on me the
ideal target density I mean I think that
one goal should be to make sure that if
water stops flowing that your fish don't
all die within you know a couple of
hours and test it see how they behave
when you shut your water off and in the
tank that's been fed within a couple of
dollars and take a look if you see them
really really stressing your density
maybe 2i your water quality may not be
adequate to support that density we
maintain sufficient no more than 10
tuition leader unless there's a really
good reason for it here like we want to
skew sex ratio or we want to run them
for some some scientifically valid
purpose I would say it's most common in
zebrafish facilities that I've spoken
with people around the world to keep
them at anywhere from two to five and
it's probably still very common five to
ten I hear the number eight toss around
a lot but it's kind of middle of the
road for five to ten one more question
real quick before I go any further with
respect to I equip requirements at what
stage do you consider embryo / lar vie
as vertebrates and must report though
and animal protocols so your aya cook or
your governing body for your institution
is free to make up their mind about this
I believe hola calls this three days now
and we call them five days but when we
when the protocols are written there
very often defined about how many of
which live stage will be needed
given research here so an embryo really
is an embryo until I can hatch on its
own and their larval fish until they
complete metamorphosis which is
typically around 14 days and then
they're no longer alar be mayor fish so
some of this is semantics and some of it
is policy and policy and it's going to
depend on your institution in the
country that you're in so a quick review
about feeding and what you can feed and
how often when they're young when
they're really young continuous here's
that 14-day mark where we say three to
five times daily it's almost continuous
if we can do it too and then as they get
older one two three maybe five times a
day depending on how much food you give
them at a given feeding so a quick
evaluation of some live feeds here's
some performance data on the left the
average size at day 12 the blue line is
rotifer fed fish this camp comes from
Chris Lawrence too thanks again chris i
have data that essentially mirrors what
Chris has here and I think almost anyone
has done this work sees the same thing
there's a prodigious amount of growth
when you compare this to our artemio fed
fish and the paramecia fed fish are
right in the middle this is probably
mostly due to the size of that organism
the ability of these fish and catch them
and eat them sorry let's skip that guy I
often get the question and emails etc
about what we're feeding here this is
the diet achill feeding as a prepared
diet from from beginning to end alpha to
Omega a to Zed we're real happy with it
the stuff has the proper ratio it flows
really well it has a two and a half year
shelf life there are a number of good
reasons to use this
food not least of which is that it's
definable in terms of its content we
have batch number information and we're
overall we're very very happy with the
performance of this food and really the
take home message is the process diet of
any kind helps to standardize the
feeding because it's easy to qualify so
how all the things that we talked about
so far one of the things that they lead
up to is the breeding of these fish so
we'll switch gears here for just about
four slides they're crepuscular stomping
spawners so that means that they'll
spawn in the morning and in the evening
but we typically and traditionally these
facilities breed them in the morning we
say when the Sun comes up they like to
breed and that's pretty much true but
they're like to do that when the sun
goes down as well and you'll find that
to be true if you leave I need
sex-segregated fish and a breeding take
over night and you look at the embryos
it's very common to find some that will
form basically when the light not
spawning k10 conditions are important
low volumes of water require tank
exchange or water exchange typically
this comes on a form of flow but I also
know people who lifts up and insert and
put it into a container of fresh water
in the morning the accumulation of those
metabolites overnight can it negatively
impact breeding success in Richmond
helps there's no question about this
what I mean is artificial plants and
imparting a gradient on the substrate or
the false bottom of the tank provides
the fish with that preferred spawning
environment there is a video here for
this one and this is a external spawning
tank with no gradient and I just want
you to observe the interactions that
behavior is the interaction behaviors
between these fish in this tank
let's advance to the next slide this is
some shallow water behaving spawning
behavior this is analogous to put in one
of those breeder tanks on an angle or
bias imparting it in some way give them
this ability to find shallow water
because that's where the females like to
and prefer to lay their eggs there is a
video for this one this is slide 52
I mean that I observed this day to day
in the facility and the female will
quite literally get themselves out of
the water and prefer to spawn there if
you want to maximize your spawning
success a couple of tips that I would
give you our keep the males and females
separate overnight it reduces the stress
because the interactions between these
fish in that setting can be pretty
aggressive use artificial plants to
provide cover fish larvae cover period
this reduces stress low volume water
flow if it's available helps to keep the
water fresh which also reduces stress
there's a theme here and the the data
that you see here below is actually some
an experiment we did here a number of
years ago using plants to identify
whether or not it was really worked at a
time and if it was really effective and
in the blue box we basically say on the
top number where we have a success rate
of 61 percent is the male has the plant
a swisher separated that the male has
the plan on the other one sixty-three
percent the female has the plant so
statistically we're not talking about a
big difference between the two but in
the red box if there are no plants
present we drop down to less than forty
six percent success rate with an in
value of 72 this is statistically
significant and if you put a blank plant
on both sides of the divider
seventy-five percent increase that
statistically an increase from choosing
one side or the other and that was 88
trials
larvae culture I'm going to breeze
through a couple of these slices we've
already covered them in in a sense in
previous section of the nutrition that
this is one of the things that is one of
the sort of early humps and difficulties
a lot of people have these are a couple
pictures of larval zebrafish they they
love to occupy different areas in the
water column you can see this sort of
slanted approached by the middle fish on
the left these fish are hunting in a
tank with here with rotifers most
important part of larvae culture is good
embryo care if you can't get the collops
and the fungi and the results of hypoxia
out of the equation you're not going to
have good success the old adage of
garbage in garbage out is very very true
there's a video here on the right these
are collops people call them tour lays
in a number of things there they're just
an absolute scourge and a petri dish of
zebrafish embryos or even larvae that
haven't been able to get moving yet Ross
can you play the video for slide 57
you
and I may have actually my apologies i
sent i sent the wrong column video but
that's a pretty good characterization of
what they look like that one's [ __ ]
false colored if they just decimate a
dish and in fact this is what your
dishes will often look like you have
these sort of remains that are almost
just they they're just a smudge on the
bottom of the dish if you see this these
are this is the result of a cob
infestation in a dish the best practice
is to move your embryos when you do your
cleanups to a new dish with new embryo
media there by trying to wash out any
contaminants including columns if you
use pipettes and last my bets fire
polishing is a really smart thing to do
you can fire polish a handful of
pipettes pretty quickly and keep them
around for a really long time I know
that if I were being handled by a glass
transfer pipette I would much prefer the
one on the right with a nice smooth edge
than the one on the left which is right
out of the box you got to do lots of
cleanups of your embryos especially if
you keep them at high density if you
don't get these dead ones out and all
the other junkie to try this out of
these dishes or get the embryos move to
new clean dishes it will kill off the
rest of them it can also call as hypoxia
the ones that do survive you'll find
more than 10,000 hits on google scholar
for zebrafish hypoxia the effects are
wide ranging from develop mental
retardation to all sorts of
abnormalities you just want to avoid it
so in terms of larvae culture meaning
growing these fish from embryo all the
way through the larval stage and into
their adulthood dzifa he says these are
the time frames that are the doll is 90
days they actually say a breeding adult
that's just not necessarily the case I
don't believe that these things are is
temporal fixed temporal variables as we
see in this chart
so here's to clear definitions in my
view on the left you see rawr be sorry
embryo still in the corium and on the
right you have Lori these fish are ready
to eat they consume most of their deal
they've got a mouth they've got a swim
bladder so the question becomes when do
you start feeding this was a quick trial
where we started some at four five and
six days even if four days these fish
were growing five days is our standard
here if you wait until six days they can
still catch up but if you wait any
longer they won't and I'll show you some
information on that in just a moment a
lot of people say you know but they're
five days old or they're six days old
well temperature impacts the development
if there are five days at 28 half
degrees then you'll see good response if
they're five days at 26 degrees you
won't and this is an example of too
early and too much water actually in the
tank as well it's too early and you can
tell because they're still using their
hashing plan to try and get near the
surface the water they do not have a
swim bladder and therefore are really
not good at eating they can't really
chase anything you need anyway so time
isn't the best where the absolute answer
here is that same chart run out to about
10 and a half days and the five-day fish
really began to outperform everybody if
you wait until seven days and I think
there are a lot of people out there to
do way until about seven days these fish
have a very hard time catching up and
that extends for the rest of their life
in fact here here we have an example of
those tend a fish these are the same
clutch of fish the ones on the Left will
offered food at four days and the ones
on the right offered food at seven days
I think the results really speak for
themselves here that chart run all the
way out to 43 actually from world past
43 but the arrows
run to 43 days post-fertilization so
those fish that we waited until seven
days were only 17 millimeters in length
and that's snout to vent length or sorry
snout to call peduncle length F way
three days compared to 22 and a half
milliliters on average for those that
were fed starting on day five so first
feeding methods and options I've got two
videos on this one they're small but
they illustrate the swimming behavior of
paramecia and they're the only videos I
have have been able to find and I want
me to see them because i want you to
notice and compare it to the rotor for
video where you saw that lumbering slow
movement this is slide 70 and there are
two videos top-left bottom-left to
compare
[ __ ] is the pause button
I
so one thing to think about is that some
of these allergies that are available
commercially are potentially useful all
is green water feeding techniques and
there are other plankton interviews in
fish culture and there's no doubt we'll
see more of those in zebrafish in the
future green water technique if you use
it make it really really dark but
provide your fish the water exchange if
possible oops I've got a quick video
here of larval fish feeding on rotifers
it's very difficult to see them so I
stuck a camera in a tank this is video
for slide 72 and I promise we're near
the end for the 60 of you that have
stepped around I appreciate it
so let me show you a couple of
photographs of what we have in in the
fish facility here all the time because
I think it's pretty enlightening to see
exactly what these tanks look like with
the fish and rotifers in them so
Rutherford's exhibit phototaxis like
lots of plankton do and so they like to
accumulate in the places where the light
is essentially focused by the shapes of
the tanks got a couple that are pretty
good so you see this tends to be a
little hazy ER in the front where the
light is these fish are all all
throughout the water column the sort of
haziness is actually the cloud of
rotifers there's probably millions of
rotifers in these tanks and initially
right after feeding they're really quite
cloudy and the fish just go bananas and
they just eat all day long now one thing
I do want to point out is that even
though there is some to try to some
salon of these tanks you don't want to
see it to excess it will start to kill
your fish it allow compete the road for
exam of fish so if something like that
happens you do have to do something
about it
so one question about rotifers and some
of these other foods is how much and how
many to to feed and really what what
I've done here is we we sort of did this
by the seat of our pants and we we
figured out what we what we liked him
and what we were being successful with
and we started to quantify we did that
by looking at how many rotifers per
milliliter were in our culture and
extrapolating by looking at how much we
reduce that harvest to how concentrated
that was and then how we took that
concentrated artist and fed it out how
many bills used to have to simply do the
math your observations will allow you to
build something of a chart like this
we're talking about a thousand rotifers
per fish per day and that's that just
seems to work well for us last less than
that is absolutely fine too now let me
go back for just a moment to talk about
how much is in these tanks and the
possibility of creating a problem in the
tank if it smells bad or if it looks
milky or easier cloudy if there's a scum
on the surface or a slick on the surface
of the water use your nose use your eyes
these are conditions that require an
action from you and you need to think
about what actions you have available to
you you need to trust your senses in
your intuition if if you wouldn't want
to be in there because it's just
absolutely foul the fish are probably
not going to do a little either so the
best things that you can do our water
exchange is the simplest and easiest
thing to do we may turn on the water in
one of these tanks and fill it up and
let it run until it's nice and clear and
then we'll take it to the same can pour
it out so that we have a reduced water
level so that when we feed it a new
batch of rotifers they still have that
nice high encounter rate you can also
use a wide natural bristle paint brush
and run it across the surface to get a
scum of water off the behavior of the
fish will indicate some of these
conditions and
there's a video here for slide number 80
this shows some of these stressed
behaviors are fished it I don't know any
other way to say it other than they look
stressed
easiest thing to do is to turn the water
on a drip here I've got it so this
illustrates the bats come has no ability
to be you know cohesive and really form
a layer if you've got to wrap a drip of
water coming into the tank it breaks the
surface tension pretty simple so your
observations are the basis for diet
changes meaning how much food and the
size of the food let them eat the things
that they can get in their mouth I like
to empower the staff and the researchers
to make decisions and avoid making
mistakes by preventing by printing a
graphic tool like this that allows them
to see what food and what type of
feeding regime their fish are ready for
next these are printed out on stickers
and these adorn all the fish racks all
over the place they're really handy so
one one question I get asked a lot and
there is I believe a video for this one
perhaps not this is adult fish feeding
on rivers you can even tell from this
still image these fish are just excited
they know what's coming they love the
smell they love the taste of it and they
remember it from being very young and
they just go crazy to eat these 30 to 50
micron organisms even as it rolls
stocking density hopefully the person
who asked the question about stocking
density is still around it's
particularly when you switch a really
young stocking density can can have a
downstream effect temperature can too
but stocking densities wanted we have a
lot more control over typically than
that temperature we typically leave our
temperature at a set point and in this
case the take-home message is the more
fish in a tank the more males you're
going to have not exactly sure all the
mechanisms that play there
but that really does seem to be the case
this was some of the raw data and really
even at low temperature a high density
yielded way way more males than females
there were only three out of 206 fish or
209 fish that became female and in a
really high seven fish per liter in that
case this is in a different facility but
take-home message is still the same this
is another chart about feeding your
about your dosages these charts are not
meant to be instructive for your
particular purposes don't don't just
take these and run with them you can
take the format its use and the map it's
used and use that but these numbers may
not work well in your situation but
those charts are available for everybody
to make good and educated decisions on
about how much food needs to be made
every day and while greater than 90 days
sexual maturity is really common using
this approach less than 60 days can be
the normative facility lots of smaller
feedings and avoid the temptation if you
did excess and by that I mean lots of
waste in the tanks keep those tanks free
of that excessive to try this place it
turns them off to eating so here's a
40-day fish buys ef'n standard this is a
jew little fish this fish went straight
from the microscope to a breeding tank
and gave me a clutch over 100 I did or
so so it can be done that's 28
millimeters snout to call the peduncle
other people to measure total length
this may be a 32 or 33 millimeter fish
when are they ready to breed not 90 days
whenever they look like they're ready to
breed females look rabid when they're
grabbing
and then they're ready to breed that
could be 60 days it can be 40 days and
depending on your methodology it could
be even longer environmental enrichment
it's used in specific situations like
low housing numbers same sex housing
spawning tanks and recovery tanks here
is a video of a tank without any cover
in it and the next slide is a video of
one that does have a plant in it so the
effect is really pretty tremendous this
is slide 92 and only two more slides
left
something in the front of the tank that
it is work
so that'll wrap it up for me thanks for
letting me run half an hour over and
sticking with me I believe that this
presentation will be available for
anyone and everyone who's signed up to
get and I'm certainly happy to field any
additional questions either now or
you're very welcome to email me at my
email address here at Wash U if you have
any questions or would like any
clarification